hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
one of the most prestigious events of
the year in the Mr dodgy Invitational
Tournament uh 3.0 and it's a game
between affida Master camel Plato of
Poland and the world champion Magnus
Carlson it's a Blitz game uh all of the
games in this event are are Blitz it's
five plus zero so uh incredible uh time
format and no time for for uh second
guesses and there is no increment which
is especially important I I think uh for
those of you who are maybe older five
plus zero is the absolute uh favorite uh
time control uh and that's why one of
the reasons I think that so many uh
people uh decided to play in this uh a
prestigious event amongst other things
but let's check out the game and it's uh
very interesting that uh the opening
used in the game is actually the
trompowsky attack and uh camel has an
adjustable course on the thromboski he
has some other courses and what better
way at the test his knowledge of the
trompowsky than by facing world champion
Magnus Carlsen so let's see how it went
camel has the white pieces and he opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 by Magnus
and the bishop to G5 this is the
trompovsky attack uh and here uh for uh
example Knight the E4 is the main line
against the trompowsky it has depending
on the database you check about 10 000
games in the database with Knight to the
E4 played however here Magnus as he did
in all of the games decided to go for
sort of an offbeat continuation uh
something that really can't be fine
found in a database and he plays Pawn to
B5 and Knight Steve for like we said
some 10 000 games in the database Pawn
to B5 12 games in the database
so it's uh very hard to say even though
uh camel made an adjustable course and
from under trumpovsky uh where he
actually checked the B5 move but uh
especially this fact makes the game even
more interesting he goes for Bishop
captures on F6 G captures and now Pawn
to E3 okay he strengthens his Center and
he doubled magnus's g-pawn but of course
later on Magnus will use the semi-openg
file for his Rook uh Bishop to B7 and
now Knight to F3 our continuing
development of course you cannot go for
the B5 Pawn you will lose the G2 Pawn uh
and there are some games where Rook the
G8 was played but here we have pawned
the A6 and it is now already as of move
5 that we have a completely new game
uh G4 uh G3 by camel preparing to think
to his light Square bishop and pawn to
C5 Magnus strikes against the center C3
and now Pawn to E6 with Bishop to G2 and
pawn to D5 with castles uh and Magnus
goes for Knight to D7 so you can see
that Magnus has a very strong setup in
the center here Knight beat the D2 and
now Bishop to E7 we have Rook to E1 and
now Magnus Castle so he does have uh at
the G file uh semi-open and the white
could use this for his attack but with
the position so closed it's very hard to
bring those pieces in front of magnus's
King and there are basically two ideas
here you wanna play as white you wanna
go for the queen side breakthrough or
you want to go for the central
breakthrough and camel goes for E4 he
goes for the central breakthrough we
have rooked the C8 and now e captures on
D5 uh Bishop captures on D5 and now Pawn
to A4 uh so first going for E for then
A4 B E4 by Magnus and now Pawn to see
for attacking the bishop and here the
position becomes uh very very
interesting
if the bishop goes back for example
Bishop to C6 or Bishop to B7 then D5 and
black can pretty much resign there is no
way to organize a defense for the black
king uh White will just play let's say
we capture here Knight stage four Queen
to G5 check Knight to F5 and Checkmate
the black king there are ways to prolong
this but all in all white will uh White
will be victorious here so instead
Magnus goes for Bishop captures on F3 uh
this is the absolute best way to do it
Knight captures on F3 and now C captures
and D4 we have Queen captures and now
just Knight to C5 offering a trade of
Queens with the Knight now being on this
beautiful Outpost we have Queen to G4
with check King to h8 now Dora can come
to the G file and Rook 8 to D1 you don't
have to rush with
uh bringing the queen over to the H file
uh Rook 8 to D1 this is I believe Rook
a31 is one of the most famous moves in
chess in general uh played by Adolf
Anderson in a very special game so
whenever you play it I I feel that you
uh you know uh get sort of a special
feeling about the game it's okay Queen
to C7 with Queen to H5 and now Rook C to
d8 uh and here uh Rook captures on the
eighth another very very important move
by camel uh problem is if you go Knight
to H4 there's just no good way to
organize an attack here let's say Rook
captures Rook captures and now Queen E5
uh black just forces
um a trade here there's really not all
that much you you can do here uh the the
queen is being threatened and also if
you just move the queen then you lose
the B2 Pawn then you allow black to
create a past B Pawn so this wouldn't be
all that great however Rook captures on
d8 uh Queen capture 78 uh or you capture
with the rook and then you lose the F7
Pawn so Queen captures and now Knight
the H4 and this is the moment where the
magic happens uh magnus's position is
objectively better he has to play Queen
to D2 attack the B2 pawn and pretty much
whatever white plays let's say Rook D2
Queen G5 he offers a queen trade uh and
he enjoys his position however in the
game after this Knight stage for move
Magnus played Queen to D4 uh again going
for the B2 Pawn but this allows camel to
play a spectacular winning move uh that
Magnus missed so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Camel while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh the
only winning move for Camel and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night the F5 basically uh
this is where camel wanted to put his
knight uh with the entire game it just
wasn't possible until Magnus played
Queen to D4 now it's possible as you
don't really have a good continuation
your queen is hanging and the bishop on
E7 is hanging and if you try to defend
the bishop look at this just captures
captures and Bishop E4 and black can
resign Checkmate is being threatened you
cannot play F5 F5 just Bishop captures
and of course the E6 Pawn is pinned and
if you try something like Knight
captures an E4 then Rook captures on e4
and in order to organize an attack
against Rook H4 and queen captures on H7
you're gonna have to play Rook to G8
Rook to H4 Rook to G7 and now you start
pushing your past C pawn and this will
give enough
um uh well this will be enough for white
to just win the game very easily black
is tied on here completely uh defending
the black king and that's pretty much it
so Magnus doesn't go back he accepts the
Knight okay he captures an F5 Rook
captures on E7 and now Queen captures on
B2 and it seems like okay you've
defended but not really Rook captures an
F7 Queen to C1 check Bishop to F1 Rook
captures on F7 Queen captures an F7 and
here uh Magnus realizes the horror of
what he has done now the threat is Queen
to f8 which will be Checkmate and also
even if you don't Checkmate the black
king there's the problem of the hanging
Knight and there's just no good way to
handle this if you play something like
Queen to H6 uh just Queen the E8 with
track and now King the G7 Queen to E7
check again will win tonight so there's
no way to save the Knight
so instead after Queen captures an F7
Magnus plays H5 but now Queen to f8 with
check and a few more moves were played
before Carmel uh decided to capture that
Knight queen to h8 queen captures and F6
with check also why not grab a pawn
while you're at it King to G8 and now
Queen to d8 with check King F7 Queen to
C7 with check King E6 and now Queen to
B6 with check of course the king cannot
go to D5 so King D7 and now Queen
captures on C5 and now camel is up a
full Bishop uh all that uh is left is
for him to win the game
uh so Queen to B1 defending the B Pawn
uh and now Queen to D5 with check King
to C8 and now camel just starts
advancing his C Pawn C5 with B3 Pawn to
C6 now threatening check and Checkmate
King to C7 Queen to D7 check King to B6
and pawn to C7 now the other Queen is
coming into the game B2 uh C8 with queen
and now Queen captures on F1 Magnus
grabs the bishop to gain to get the
queen into the game with Tempo King
captures an F1 and B1 Queen with check
King G2 and now magnus's only hope is to
find some sort of a Perpetual Queen to e
for check F3 Queen to E2 King to H3 and
it was in this position on move 44 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once you give one more check after King
to H4 there are no more checks and now
black king will just get checkmated in
in one or two moves
uh so yeah uh really uh spectacular play
by Carmel who who played uh a brilliant
chest for the entire game and basically
the only opportunity that Magnus gave
him this queen to D4 move uh he took
advantage of Knight to F5 is the only
winning move and that's just it and also
like I said uh I I haven't seen his
course unchessable but I have seen the
intro that that he made where he talks
about what's going on there so I don't
know if he actually covered the B5 move
uh maybe he has uh but uh either way he
uh really did well against uh against
world champion Magnus Carlsen and what a
nice Victory and I think uh Magnus was
undefeated uh until this game or not
just undefeated he was on 100 in the
tournament before losing this game to
commonly in round four as these are the
standings of the Mr dodgy Invitational
so you can see Magnus finished the first
day uh with 11 uh and a half in first
place uh followed by Daniel dubo with 11
then Ralph mama with seven 10 and a half
and so on and so on 16 very very
impressive players here so if you have a
favorite of your own from the tournament
if there was a nice game because so many
games were played uh do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over it and
hopefully uh show it but yeah I mean uh
very nicely done by camel uh taking down
Magnus who is over 400 rating points
higher rated than him uh so yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you know your openings chances are you
will defeat very strong players uh like
condo did here so yeah once again big
congratulations I would like to thank
Ahmed Yusuf akihal clothesbox and
ravishing reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day